i think it was i knew very early on that
it should be a love story
um even though that even that took a bit
of grappling i remember talking to sarah
really early on and jack and harry
williams and
they were like really interesting to
know what happens if fleabag falls in
love and i was like that is not a story
i want to tell
first up it's quite exciting this
because they're going to ping onto their
uh
onto their videos okay we have ms
phoebe woolabridge creator writer actor
and executive producer of
fleabag phoebe please whichever camera
amazing this is so exciting um it's like
you're all popping out from behind
curtains
we have harry bradbeer the director of
both series of fleabag hello
harry there you are hello
we are we have guri gary dolner who
is the editor gary where are you
he's there all right and we have sarah
hammond producer
sarah are you there hello
and we have sean clifford amazing actor
hello
sean are you there hello
we're all virtually together this is
fantastic so i'd like to obviously
congratulate you
not only on a wonderful series but on
your nominations you have uh three
nominations
for the uh tv awards three nominations
in the craft awards and
also a nomination for uh the the moment
which um uh we can uh we can describe as
perhaps the
uh the confession scene this is voted
for by the public you could have a
nomination for that
uh i imagine that uh it's the virgin's
must-see moment i imagine you'll have
quite a few
votes for that one okay so we're going
to start off we're going to rewind
okay rewind imagine we go back and we go
back
to the clip that everyone has just seen
which is right at the beginning
of series two okay the
the series begins 371 days 19 hours and
20
26 minutes after the first series uh
and we begin in a restaurant
it's it's an unusual episode i would say
it's almost theatrical
it's a one scene episode we do go to the
toilet a little bit and we go outside
for a cigarette but it's a one scene
episode we all do
yeah i mean you know this is life uh i
suppose what i wanted to do
to know really is the ambitions for that
first episode and i'm going to start
with you phoebe because it starts with
you phoebe
so what were the ambitions what did you
feel like you had to do
and wanted to do with that first episode
well i um first of all i wanted to
be able to recap everything without
recapping everything so
um if you know what i mean without it
being kind of expositional because it
had been
two years since the last series and even
though
um there would have been a you know
there was a brilliant recap anyway to
actually show what's happened but the
emotional um
updating of where everybody was was the
biggest challenge
um the first image i had ever
uh for when when thinking about the
second season
was fleabag it looked that that whole
opening
um uh scene with fleabag looking up and
she's got the blood down
even the song i had in my head and
everything i had no idea what happened
i just was like that is how it's and
that's how it's opening
and i told like all the gang and
everyone everyone was like i mean yeah
that just feels exactly like it should
open but like what happens next i was
like i don't know
and that's often how it works i think so
these really strong images
and then the fun bit is kind of piecing
together the puzzle of whatever feels
right instinctively with that image and
then working out
why that image feels so right um
originally the
i wrote so many different terrible
drafts of a terrible versions of the
first episode
harry your face is so funny um
and you look serious and
and give me one of the give me one of
the terrible versions because i always
quite like to know the
the utre ones before you get to the real
thing
gosh i can't i have buried them so deep
in my mind and don't any of you
dare
always it was the feeling of having to
um like set up her new life does she
still have the cafe
does she work somewhere so i had lots of
different versions when she was working
in the cafe but certain things had
happened and then this one big event
happens in the cafe or she was temping
and there was a new boss
all of these different things were
flying around and the idea of a
dinner party was always sketched out i
knew there was going to be one but it
was always sketched out to be sort of
episode three
and then um at some point in the
writing process probably as they all
were these big decisions quite
tight to the wire um just decided to
jump
straight in with that uh with that
episode
and then the moment um we discussed that
and it was you know jenny robbins was
our story producers in the room as well
and we wanted to discuss the idea of
doing that and the moment i sat down i
was actually in the room with the guys
the moment
i sat down i was like yeah maybe let's
try this and then i just started writing
the episode and it started pouring out
because it seems like the clearest way
to get
um to feel the tensions without having
to explain them
to people um and also the whole point
the whole
sort of vibe of feedback for me is
people having to pretend that they're
okay
when they're not okay and there's
nothing like a kind of family
dinner party um to put that pressure on
people so that's
sort of unraveled and it was very
exciting working out that it was
actually martin who punched fleabag and
that was a real like eureka moment but
it sort of went backwards from that
moment
yeah that's great it could have been
anyone couldn't it really could have
could be a passing waitress
but uh i was going to say also about
that
particular scene because obviously
everybody is familiar in that scene
apart from one character who is
we can just call him the hot priest so
he is the one
new character that obviously takes
everything in a whole
new direction everyone else we might
know even if you
you know if you come to the series
having not watched the first series you
can kind of work them out he is a
completely new
and specific uh element and i suppose i
wanted to know
when you arrived at him
being there well
this character first of all the most
expressible important to
to say that i didn't call him the hot
priest the internet did
you see what you do at the end did you
believe i'm sorry both of both of you
call him
you say he's hot you go hot no no
fleabag does but in the script the
character was always just called the
priest
of all my years of complaining that
women in scripts are described but as
like
like you know sandra beautiful walks in
a room and then it's like
a man then it's because you know all
that myself was very important to me
that he is that he was described as the
priest
fleabag does describe him and claire
later on but um
i think it was i knew very early on that
it should be a love story
um even though that even that took a bit
of grappling i remember talking to sarah
really early on and jack and harry
williams and
they were like really interesting to
know what happens if fleabag falls in
love and i was like that is not a story
i want to tell
you it shouldn't be defined but a lot of
this q a is going to be
me saying that me barking at the
brilliant ideas of my producers and
directors
director and before realizing they were
brilliant but um
so yeah but then i really did know i
wanted to see a love story
on screen i felt like that's something i
really wanted to to
once i just wanted as an audience wanted
to see it so
that's always a really good first port
of call um and then
realizing there should be a character
who fleabag can't
just sum up in a in a quick line like
the first
the whole of the first series is her
describing people as tube rodent or
[ __ ] guy and she's
she considers herself to be able to see
people very very quickly at their core
and it was really exciting the idea of
her meeting somebody who she couldn't
define and she tries to and she says
cool sweary priest at the beginning um
and that's like
should have been like the end of it and
and then i really wanted to find
somebody who could
match her intelligence and her
perceptiveness
and then also by making him um
uh you know a priest and a man of faith
and a celibate man
uh just made the whole thing even more
tense for obvious reasons
um so that's sort of and then but then
every time i was sort of trying to write
him it just felt like it was almost too
much of a kind of sitcom set up
it's sort of a girl who's obsessed with
sex in the first season it's her way of
validating herself meeting a guy who
can't do that
and then the moment the idea of andrew
came into my head it was just like
that's um he's it instantly becomes
complex and interesting and then
it was just writing for andrew is just a
joy because you know you don't have to
say a huge amount and he's going to
imbue it with so much
brilliance um and also that she
she has a relationship with the camera
the whole way through um
and it was interesting to have somebody
who has a similar thing
he's he he's mirrored because he has god
and she's witnessed by
the camera the whole way through and in
the end the big question for her is
whether or not she can let go of the
camera
and he is witnessed by god the whole
time and there's always having to like
check into that whole time at the end he
has the same question so it just felt
like it was a really good
way to mirror uh each other's journeys
yeah beautiful parallel
uh sean i want to bring you in really
quickly because
it says right at the very beginning of
um of this series of feedback that it is
a love story that's
what you what you say but it's also it's
a love story between the sisters as well
i mean they
they are points there are points where
you say
where it is said you know you can't
we're not friends we're sisters
you know that's a different thing but it
is
almost not a romance but a an
acknowledgement
of the love between the two sisters in
the in the arc of the
of the second series and even you know
um feedback with her father and i think
there are so many strands of it to the
story but i think the big theme
that sort of spoke to me about the whole
series which i think is something
valuable that we can
all take away with us especially right
now is that you know we might not
like each other but we love each other
um and um
and that's so clear i think between
between those
those two women how much they will just
they they fiercely depend on one another
and will fight for each other to the
death
but they'll also fight each other to the
death
yeah they can't they can't live with or
without each other
and i yeah i loved i loved that
narrative
and um phoebe and i spoke about it
while she was developing it i knew that
was something that was really important
to her to tell that
story for them to find their way back to
each other after
um claire's betrayal at the end of
series one
and i just yeah i you know the way that
phoebe has created that um
was you know more beautiful than
anything i could have imagined because
it's so complex and it's so
real it feels so real because it's not a
straight line it's like
it's all over the place which it would
be
very raw at certain points
[Music]
you